so the world's gonna end  bummer but I hope it doesn't end in a  really sucky way like what if it ends by  our butt cheeks fusing together but our  intestines still work normally and then  we just fill up with crap and then we  explode or what if everybody's messed up  tattoos suddenly become real and then  they all kill us  that would suck or maybe everybody's  delete key just stops working but in  reality every time you touch it a person  gets deleted or maybe you wake up one  morning and every time you look at  someone a baby fills out you just drown  in babies tons and tons of babies  maybe our belly buttons come alive and  they have teeth and they eat us from the  inside out that would suck really hard  or what if every diet that you've ever  tried suddenly works but retro actively  so you lose every single pound that  you'd ever hope to lose all at the same  time anyways I hope it goes quick and I  wish I had eaten more desserts